und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend ein adliger im Seniorenalter
eine Richterin einen ehemaliger
Bundeswehroffizier das sind nicht die
Leute mit denen man in Filmen die Rollen
von Terroristen besetzen würde die
stellt man sich anders vor genau darin
liegt aber auch ein Problem
Radikalisierungen nicht ernst genug zu
nehmen sich nicht vorstellen zu können
dass solche Leute sowas tun würden einen
gewaltsam staatsstreichplan Tötung von
Politikern Sturm aufs Parlament
letzteres weckt Erinnerungen an die
Ereignisse in den USA beim Sturm aus
Kapitol waren ja auch viele Zeitgenossen
dabei die nicht ins filmtypische
terroristenprofilpassten
die Polizeiaktion heute in Deutschland
war eine der größten die jemals hier zu
Lande gegen Extremisten durchgeführt
wurde Kai Felix Jochens berichtet
Frankfurt am Main am Morgen Heinrich der
13 Prinz Reus wird abgeführt der adelige
soll der Kopf des terroristischen
Netzwerks sein dass einen Umsturz in
Deutschland herbeiführen wollte so der
Generalbundesanwalt
die Vereinigung hat sich nach unseren
Erkenntnissen zum Ziel gesetzt die
bestehende staatliche Ordnung in
Deutschland die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und der
Einsatz von Gewalt und militärischen
Mitteln zu beseitigen in insgesamt 11
Bundesländern schlagen die Ermittler zu
darüber hinaus auch in Kitzbühel
Österreich und Perugia Italien 25
Personen aus dem Reichsbürger und
verschwörungsmilieu werden festgenommen
und 150 Objekte durchsucht eine neue
Qualität die Gruppe soll in den
Sicherheitsbehörden sehr gut vernetzt
gewesen sein ein sogenannter
militärischer Arm sollte den geplanten
staatsstreichwohl unterstützen unter den
Festgenommenen auch Bundeswehrsoldaten
geübt im Umgang mit der Waffe es sei
versucht worden weitere Soldaten und
Polizisten zu rekrutieren
einzelne Mitglieder der terroristischen
Vereinigung haben sich nach unserer
Erkenntnis auch mit Überlegungen
getragen
gewaltsam in den Deutschen Bundestag
einzudringen in Kombination mit der
Festnahme der umstrittenen Berliner
Richterin mal sagt winkemann lässt das
besonders aufhorchen als ehemalige
Bundestagsabgeordnete der AFD ist die
bestens vertraut mit dem deutschen
Parlament hat weiter Zugang zum Gebäude
für eine Gruppe die im Verdacht steht
sich dort bewaffnet Zutritt verschaffen
zu wollen wäre so eine Person sehr
wertvoll natürlich ist das bitter wenn
jemand betroffen ist der noch Zugang zum
deutschen Bundestag hat als ehemalige
Abgeordnete ich gehe davon aus dass die
Bundestagsverwaltung da heute auch
schnell reagiert hat aus der Ampel
Fraktion ein scharfer Kommentar zur
möglichen Verwicklung der ehemaligen AFD
Abgeordneten
wenn sich diese ersten Berichte
bestätigen dass eine ehemalige
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete in diese
Verschwörung verstrickt ist dann zeigt
das in welchem Sumpf sich die AFD als
Partei befindet die afd-spitze nimmt
Stellung in einem gemeinsamen statement
wir verurteilen solche Bestrebungen und
lehnen diese nachdrücklich ab einen
weiter konsequenten Kurs kündigt die
bundesinnenministerin an Reichsbürger
verbinde nur der Hass auf die Demokratie
und die Menschen die sich für sie
einsetzen
deswegen gehen wir auch mit aller
rechtsstaatlichen Härte dagegen vor
diese harte Gangart werden wir
fortsetzen denn es geht um den Schutz
unserer Demokratie die festgenommenen
Personen werden nach Karlsruhe gebracht
und dem Haftrichter vorgeführt Heinrich
der 13 Prinz Reus aus Hessen der als
Kopf des terroristischen Netzwerks gilt
das mutmaßlich die Regierung stürzen
wollte ist bereits in Untersuchungshaft
bei uns ist der Präsident des
Bundeskriminalamts Holger Mönch
gelernter München ihre Behörde war mit
ein paar tausend Leuten heute bei diesen
Aktien beteiligt warum genau jetzt sie
haben die schon länger beobachtet warum
war es jetzt so konkret dass die Sachen
da müssen wir jetzt aber losschlagen nun
unser Ziel war genug Beweise zusammen
dass hier eine touristische Vereinigung
vorliegt Mitglieder der terroristischen
Einigung festzustellen und deren
Unterstützer unser Ziel war jetzt nicht
den Abstimmung mit den
Generalbundesanwalt bis zum letzten
Moment zu warten sondern wenn genug
vorhanden ist dann noch einen solchen
Einsatz zu planen und der war sehr sehr
groß und den mussten wir dann auch
sorgfältig vorplanen aber es war schon
so dass sie das Gefühl hatten da steht
jetzt was bevor das war konkret ja wir
wussten dass es Planung gibt wir wussten
aber nicht wann und darüber steht auch
immer noch keine Klarheit das werden
noch die weiteren Ermittlungen zeigen
aber diese Struktur die wir hier
aufgefunden haben einen Rat der
sozusagen Beschlüsse für diese
Vereinigung trifft in einem
militärischer Arm der versucht bewusst
Strukturen aufzubauen auch
Ausrüstungsgegenstände und auch Waffen
zu beschaffen und da warten Sie nicht
bis zum letzten Augenblick sondern wenn
das dann klar ist dann heißt es auch
zuschlagen und deshalb haben wir heute
25 festen haben durchgeführt bei
mittlerweile 54 Beschuldigten sind wir
angekommen weil auch jetzt ja wieder
neue Erkenntnis hinzukommen und bei
schon über 150 Durchsuchungen sind wir
mittlerweile gelandet Durchsuchungen
gehen auch noch weiter ja natürlich
werden wir jetzt auch auswerten was wir
finden und wir werden dann auch
wahrscheinlich noch weitere Beschuldigte
feststellen davon gehe ich aus und auch
noch weitere Durchsuchungen in den
nächsten Tagen wahrscheinlich machen das
ist ja jetzt eine erste Feststellung die
wir treffen wie wir werden noch ganz
ganz viele als erwarte über das nennen
Beweismittel mitnehmen die auswerten um
dann genauer zu schauen wie weit waren
die Planung im Detail und vielleicht
gibt es auch noch weitere Personen die
wir jetzt feststellen werden das ist
nicht auszuschließen die Sachen gerade
der militärische Vereinigung gegründet
hatte der ist dann besonders
besorgniserregend für eine Militär in
Sicherheitsbehörden ist also Menschen
die Zugang von Berufswegen zu Waffen
haben und sich das vorstellt die GSG9
durchsucht da jetzt an seine
Spezialeinheit der Bundespolizei
durchsuche eine Spezialeinheit der
Bundeswehr mit den Kommando
Spezialkräfte da kann er mir dann schon
mulmig werden wer da so offenbar so
alles sitzt die meisten sind ehemalige
Angehörige das muss man sagen aber die
auch teilweise legal im Besitz von
Waffen noch sind und das macht natürlich
besondere Risiken aus wir sind insgesamt
bei 50 Objekten davon ausgegangen dass
wir auf Waffen treffen können deshalb
auch so viele Spezialkräfte und keine
Risiken einzugehen und wir haben auch 50
Objekten Waffen gefunden von der
Armbrust und der Steinschleuder bis hin
zur Pistole unser Langwaffe und auch
Munition aber die Leute waren dann so
überrascht dass da keiner unsicht
geschossen hat wir waren so gut
vorbereitet das ist glücklicherweise
nicht zu Zwischenfällen gekommen ist
bleibt trotzdem noch mal die Frage
müsste man nicht noch genauer hingucken
wer sich in Sicherheitsorganen bewegt
das ist ja nicht das erste Mal dass man
bei der Bundeswehr oder auch bei der
Polizei Leute findet die irgendwelche
sturzpläne haben und Privatarmeen
gründen wollen das häuft sich oder häuft
sich die Erkenntnis ich glaube es ist
beides natürlich dass man auf der einen
Seite sind wir viel aufmerksamer und wir
haben ja auch jetzt übers ganze Jahr
hinweg mehr und mehr diese Ermittlung
verdichte den letzten drei Monaten
unglaublich viel investiert unglaublich
viel Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchgeführt
um hier die Strukturen noch zu erkennen
und die Person zu identifizieren und
dann stoßen sie eben auch auf viele
ehemalige auch schon suspendierte
Polizisten also ist ja nicht so dass
auch solche Personen dann nicht
teilweise noch bekannt sind und man
schon dagegen vorgeht aber die
Beweismittel teilweise auch fehlen und
von daher ist es auch wirklich jetzt
etwas was uns auch hilft Person aber die
noch im Staatsdienst sind dann auch zu
entfernen noch ganz ganz kurz zum
Schluss also viele denken immer noch
wenn sie jetzt sehen wer da so alles
dabei ist das sind ja Spinner also
verschwörungsgläubige die Familie von
diesem Prinzen hat gesagt ein verwirrte
alter Mann also harmlos ist es dann eben
nicht nein wenn ähm nur weil man an
wirklich
Glaubenssätze vereinen sich trägt die
wir auch als abwegig bezeichnen würden
heißt man nicht dass du dass man
deswegen ungefährlich ist ist ja glaube
ich auch kein kluger Gedanke zu glauben
wenn man als Märtyrer jetzt Ungläubige
tötet dass man deswegen 72
jungfernaufein warten also Sie haben es
in vielen Zusammenhängen dass Menschen
die sich radikalisieren sich so stark an
ihre Glaubenssätze Klammern dass sie
dann noch zu Gewalt greifen das ist hier
das gefährlich danke dass Sie bei uns im
Studio waren für die Einschätzung sehr
gerne
ja Bedrohung von innen und Bedrohung von
außen mit einem Angriffskrieg in Europa
jede Bundesregierung hatte immer mit
Krisen zu kämpfen und Schonzeiten gibt
es in der Weltgeschichte eh nicht aber
diese neue Bundesregierung ist gleich in
ihrem ersten Amts ja schon sehr speziell
gefordert groß zum Feiern scheint zum
Jahrestag da aber auch dann keine zumute
zu sein nicht in solchen Zeiten
Beobachtungen von Bernd Benzin und lass
sie Seefeld
den ersten Jahrestag der Ampel verbringt
der Vizekanzler 12 Flugstunden 9000 km
entfernt von Berlin in Johannesburg auf
der Suche nach neuen
energiepartnerschaften und guten
Beziehungen
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
ich bin hier auf Dienstreise in
Südafrika beim Wirtschaftskongress und
hätten sie mich nicht darauf
angesprochen ich hätte nicht gewusst
dass es der Jahrestag ist
begonnen hat diese Koalition mit einem
Harmonie selfie in einer anderen Epoche
vor dem Krieg SPD Grüne und FDP
versammelten sich unter dem Leitgedanken
mehr Fortschritt Wagen Putins Überfall
auf die Ukraine aber erschüttert alles
wir erleben eine Zeitenwende und das
bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor
vor allem der SPD fällt die Kurswende
schwer auch sie hatte jahrelang auf
Verständigung mit Russland gesetzt und
mit Putin jetzt muss sie sich das als
Fehler eingestehen wir haben gesehen was
er
gemacht hat in Georgien wir haben die
völkerrechtswidrige Lektion der Krim
gesehen das was mich beschäftigt ist
natürlich warum hat man diese Klarheit
in den Jahren davor nicht gab es gilt
aber nicht nur für die SPD sondern es
geht für das politische System insgesamt
die Folgen des Krieges fordern schnelles
Handeln hohe Preise drohnender
energiekollaps die Koalitionäre
beschließen Milliarden Entlastungen für
Wirtschaft und Bürger erfinden eine
gasumlage die scheitert bevor sie
überhaupt eingeführt wird und bei der
Frage ob Atomkraftwerke länger laufen
sollen oder nicht arbeiten Grüne und FDP
öffnen dich gegeneinander es hilft nur
noch eine Richtlinien Entscheidung des
Kanzlers
die Koalition hat in der Tat einen
anderen Politikstil verabredet und ist
an der harten Wirklichkeit gescheitert
da haben sich die beiden wichtigsten
Minister des Kabinetts einen
wochenlangen öffentlichen Schlagabtausch
geleistet das war nicht normal
jedenfalls nicht für eine gut
funktionierende Regierung
die Ampel hat den Mindestlohn erhöht und
ein neues Bürgergeld auf den Weg
gebracht der Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien soll bald stark an Fahrt
aufnehmen dennoch das dauerhafte
Krisenmanagement blockiert vieles von
dem was eigentlich kommen sollte
haben einen enormen
modernisierungsstauber Bildung bei der
Digitalisierung bei der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur bei den sauberen
Technologien das muss jetzt
aufgearbeitet werden und das sind große
Anstrengungen
und das geht jetzt so in dem
zusammenarbeitsstil weiter der ist ja
gut
die Koalitionäre beschwören den
Zusammenhalt und wollen ruhigen
Arbeitsmodus demonstrieren ein Jahr nach
dem Start der Ampel und angesichts
dramatische Herausforderungen scheint
das nötiger denn je
und der Vizekanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck ist
uns aus Johannesburg zugeschaltet zur
Zeit in rauf Reisen Afrika guten Abend
Herr Beck
guten Abend sie sind jetzt gerade weit
weg von Deutschland und aber hier ist
heute das große Thema dass wir
Vizekanzler einer Regierung sind die im
Prinzip gewaltsam weggeputscht werden
sollte mutmaßlich was sagen sie dazu
ja das habe ich mitbekommen ich muss da
sagen tatsächlich sagen mitbekommen weil
der Tag hier durch andere Termine
definiert war und es ist einerseits
natürlich erschreckend und andererseits
gut dass wir uns dagegen werden können
und dass die Aufklärung und die Polizei
dort ihren Job gemacht hat und ich
glaube genauso muss man es machen wir
leben in einer Zeit die
auch solche Taten nicht ausschließt ich
glaube nicht dass jemand damit rechnen
kann dass die deutsche Demokratie Weg
geputzt werden kann aber das
terror-angriffe Geschehen das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen das ist schlimm genug das
sagen zu müssen und entsprechend muss
der Rechtsstaat mit seinen Mitteln in
der ganzen Härte die er aufbringen kann
dagegen vorgehen
es ist so ein bisschen wie ein weiteres
Ausrufezeichen an diesem Jahrestag am
Ende eines irrwitzigen Jahres oder wie
würden sie ihr erstes Jahr als
Bundesminister beschreiben
nicht ganz so also natürlich ist eine
Menge passiert aber viele Dinge sind
auch nicht passiert und das schließt
auch
den sogenannten heißen Herbst
Volksaufstände was alles da gesagt wurde
bisher jedenfalls mit ein
sondern das Land steht stark und stabil
in einer schwierigen Situation da und
stark und stabil meint nicht
ausdrücklich nicht das ist nicht enorme
Herausforderungen gibt und Krisen gibt
und zu hohe Preise gibt für die
Wirtschaft für die VerbraucherInnen für
die Verbraucher aber der demokratische
Konsens der steht und deswegen noch mal
mit Blick auf das was heute bekannt
wurde
Einzelgruppen mögen
Umsturz Fantasien und
verschwörungstheoretische Absichten
verfolgen aber die Demokratie in
Deutschland hat sich in diesem letzten
Jahr außerordentlich bewährt bewährt
heißt nicht dass es keine Debatten gab
auch keine Kritik gehabt das ist ja ja
albern sowas auch nur zu denken oder zu
fordern aber wir sind weit gekommen wir
haben viele Sachen als Land richtig
gemacht und sind sie jetzt gerade wieder
eben durch den Krieg und durch die
Energieprobleme die wir dadurch bekommen
haben mit ihrer Hauptbeschäftigung
beschäftigt nämlich durch die Welt zu
reisen und neue Energiequellen zu suchen
und dann kommen auch immer Projekte wie
jetzt gerade in Namibia da waren sie an
einen wasserstoffprojekt aber das wird
alles erst dann in ein paar Jahren
geschehen wie überbrücken wir denn die
nächsten zwei drei Jahre damit wir nicht
ewig solch hohe Gas und Strompreise
haben
aber das ist doch erstmal eine gute
Nachricht dass bei aller Not des Tages
oder des Jahres 22 23
konsequent daran gearbeitet wird die
eigentliche Aufgabe unserer Zeit nämlich
eine klimaneutrale Wirtschaft
hinzubekommen nicht aus den Augen
verloren wird sondern ganz im Gegenteil
sich auch andere Länder auf den Weg
machen das für sich und mit uns
gemeinsam zu tun also insofern würde ich
sagen genau andersrum ist die Deutung
trotz der großen Kraftanstrengung die
wir ja im Moment aufbringen müssen
gelingt es solche Partnerschaften zu
schmieden und nach vorne zu bringen
also runter gehen nun ja genau das ist
in vier Jahren in fünf Jahren aber jetzt
müssen wir ja jetzt erstmal heizen und
Strom erzeugen und sie wollen
strompreisbremse behalten ja
genau sage ich gleich aber russlandka
die namibia hat drei Windkraftanlagen 3
jetzt haben die vor ein riesenpark zu
bauen in vier Jahren das ist schon fast
unvorstellbar dass das gelingen kann
aber sie sehen wie groß die Ambition ist
und vier Jahre von einem für ein Land
das gar nichts hat ist doch super Afrika
hat einen Prozentanteil von erneuerbaren
Energien von 1%, das ganze Afrika mit
der Wind und der Sonne die der Afrika
aufzubieten hat dass sie sich auf den
Weg machen da würde ich sagen gut ab
Leute bisschen spät aber super wenn ihr
loslaufen so jetzt zu Ihrer Frage indem
wir eine Infrastruktur bauen ich habe es
ja mehrfach erklärt das Problem in
Deutschland ist dass das Gas nicht nach
Deutschland reinkommt wir haben alle
unsere Karten auf Nordstemmen eins
gesetzt die Leitungen sind kaputt Putin
hat nicht mehr geliefert der will auch
nicht mehr liefern also müssen wir
andere Infrastrukturen schaffen und wenn
wir das geschafft haben dann kann der
Weltmarkt wieder oder hat Deutschland
wieder ist Deutschland wieder Teil des
Gas Weltmarktes bis wir besseres
aufgebaut haben und genau das tun wir
schon in diesem Jahr und im ja kommt in
der nächste große Schritt aber dann
werden die Preise auch wieder
runtergehen nach dem Winter 24
spätestens werden die Gaspreise wieder
runtergehen aber ist das nicht ein eines
der Probleme mit denen sie auch zu
kämpfen haben weil es auch irgendwo
paradox ist wir sagen wir wollen zum
Beispiel kein Tracking in Deutschland um
Gottes Willen und dann kaufen wir aber
Gas ein das genau so hergestellt wird
auch in Namibia gibt es ja Leute die
sagen oh diese Windanlagen diese
wasserstoffanlage die sollen am
Naturschutzgebiet entstehen das wollen
viele dort auch nicht also wir lagern
eigentlich unsere eigenen Probleme nach
außen oder
aber das ist keine neue Erkenntnis das
ist zuzugeben wenn man so will aber wir
haben in Deutschland die
Steinkohleförderung eingestellt wir
haben uns gegen Tracking entschieden wir
haben auch kaum noch eigene Ölproduktion
das hat noch niemanden interessiert die
letzten Jahre sondern wir haben es
dankbar genommen wenn es aus Russland
oder auch Saudi Arabien kam jetzt auf
einmal reden wir darüber und das finde
ich gut wir sollten sehen dass wir uns
möglichst selber auch der Verantwortung
stellen nur sollten wir uns der
richtigen Verantwortung stellen und die
Energieform der Zukunft möglichst stark
aufbauen und die Energieform der Zukunft
wird wieder Kohle noch Gas noch Öl sein
sondern eine erneuerbare Energiewelt die
klimaneutral ist das heißt die
Konsequenz aus dem was sie fordern ist
kein not in my backyard kein darum
kümmere ich mich das soll andere machen
für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
mit all seinen Konsequenzen die ja auch
schwierig sind und auch da hat sich das
Land im letzten Jahr auf dem Weg gemacht
Bayern
eine Windkraft Zahlen verdoppeln will
reicht noch nicht aber immerhin ich
meine es ist Bayern ja und das ist doch
mal einen Schritt nach vorne wollen wir
nicht über die Windkrafträder in Bayern
reden weil in ganz Deutschland verzögert
sich der Aufbau von von eigener
Windkraft und es bleibt ja schwierig
wenn wir jetzt noch einmal auf das
vergangene Jahr zurück gucken was war
für Sie persönlich da der bleibt
es bleibt natürlich schwierig nichts ist
einfach
mehr Windkraftanlagen aber es zieht an
es zieht an und das ist schon mal viel
wir werden sehen wie dicht wir in diesem
Jahr an die geplanten Ziele für 22 für
den Ausbau von Windkraft kommen und im
nächsten Jahr müssen wir wieder mehr
machen und dann wieder mehr wir müssen
immer mehr machen das ist richtig aber
es gibt Fortschritte was war aus ihrer
Sicht in diesem einem Jahr
ampelregierung der problematische Moment
oder Tiefpunkt der Ärger um die
gasumlage als sie da ziemlich alleine
standen oder dass der Kanzler macht wird
zum Atom
sprechen musste
nein das war ein beides keine Tiefpunkte
das war jetzt nicht in erfreulicher
Prozess aber das ist normale
Verantwortung im Amt das bestimmte Dinge
noch mal anders um und
entschieden werden und dann macht man
das nächste Projekt das ist kein
persönlicher Tiefpunkt gar nicht
überhaupt hat das mit persönlichen
tiefer und mir gar nichts zu tun sondern
dass wir als Regierung in dieser Zeit
die richtigen Dinge entscheiden und ich
räume ein dass wir manchmal mehr
Debatten Zeit gebraucht haben aber
wie kann man das wirklich vorwerfen wenn
ich das mal so fragen darf ich meine das
sind alles Parteien in einem
öffentlichen Raum der öffentliche Raum
ist vermachtet ist voller Interessen ist
permanent unter Beobachtung jeden Tag
gibt es neue Umfragen die die Personen
bewerten die die Parteien bewerten es
gibt Wahlkämpfe es ist ja geradezu eine
illusionistische Vorstellung wie
Demokratie funktioniert wenn man sagt
man dann setzen sich halt drei Typen hin
kehren die Sache und keiner widerspricht
so läuft es nun mal nicht in Deutschland
und das ist doch gut das ist nicht so
läuft sondern dass wir die die Kultur
einer offenen Debatte haben genau das
was übrigens die potenziellen Attentäter
stört die wollen genau das Abschaffen
nun ja das ist manchmal nicht ganz schön
anzuhören anzusehen aber es hat uns doch
in die Lage des große wichtige gute
Entscheidung zu treffen im
Energiebereich im Finanzbereich im
handelspolitischen Bereich im
klimaschutzbereich und insofern wir
haben uns als Land ich bleibe dabei in
diesem Jahr außerordentlich bewährt sagt
danke für das Gespräch
danke Ihnen
das Interview haben wir am Abend
aufgezeichnet zu einem Jahr
ampelregierung nun einen Kommentar von
der Chefredakteurin des ZDF Bettina
Schausten
im Honeymoon mit Weichzeichner selfie
und
ermöglichungsrhetorik ist diese
Regierung gestartet jetzt nach einem
Jahr Ampel ist der Befund eindeutig der
Lack ist ab wer in diesen Tagen für das
erste Jahr Noten verteilt und das tun
die Koalitionäre gerne auch selbst kommt
über einen befriedigend nicht hinaus
wohlwollend betrachtet weniger
wohlwollend landet man
angesichtsverunglückter gasumlagenpläne
und der dauerzankerei zwischen Grünen
und FDP noch darunter hat es Urteil oder
falsche Ansprüche noch jede Regierung
hat im ersten Jahr der Legislatur in den
Umfragen verloren in aller Regel
jedenfalls weil Erwartungen meistens
enttäuscht werden und dieses
Dreierbündnis hätte wohl auch in
normalen Zeiten an Glanz verloren nicht
zuletzt wegen der weltanschaulichen
maximal Distanz von Grün und Gelb das
krisenhafte erste Jahr lässt den
Realitätscheck jetzt allerdings
gnadenlos Ausfallen der russische
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
zeitenwände Energiekrise und nur noch
ein Umsturz Versuch durch rechtsextreme
Verfassungsfeinde wie zur Bestätigung
die Ampel muss sich durchschlagen um das
Schlimmste zu verhindern in jeder
Hinsicht ja der Lack ist ab Kratzer sind
offensichtlich und man darf sogar fragen
wie lange die Karre noch fährt aber sie
fährt und das ist eine gute Nachricht
jetzt möchte man dem Mann am Steuer nur
zurufen bitte einen Gang zulegen
und jetzt schauen wir auf andere
Nachrichten dieses tageseins die
EU-Kommission will ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland auf den
Weg bringen kommissionspräsidentin von
der Leyen schrieb auf Twitter wir stehen
an der Seite der Ukraine und lassen
Russland für seine Grausamkeiten
bezahlen dem EU-Außenbeauftragten Borell
zufolge geht es bei den Sanktionen etwa
um Mitglieder des russischen Militärs
der Verteidigungsindustrie sowie der
Regierung
als Reaktion auf die veränderte
Sicherheitslage auch infolge des
russischen Angriffs Kriegs gegen die
Ukraine will die Bundesregierung die
sogenannte kritische Infrastruktur in
Deutschland besser schützen das Kabinett
beschloss dazu Eckpunkte für einen
entsprechendes Gesetz das bis Sommer
nächsten Jahres in Kraft treten soll zu
den kritischen Infrastrukturen zählt das
Innenministerium unter anderem Bereiche
wie Energie Gesundheit und Trinkwasser
einen Monat nach den sogenannten mit
terms in den USA bauen die Demokraten
von Präsident Joe Biden ihre hauchdünne
Mehrheit im Senat aus im Bundesstaat
Georgia hat der demokratische Senator
Warnock die Stichwahl gegen seinen
republikanischen Herausforderer Walker
gewonnen der Wahlsieg des Demokraten
gegen den Republikaner gilt auch als ein
weiterer Rückschlag für Ex-Präsident
Trump der 2024 ins Amt zurück will und
Walker unterstützt hatte
chinas Führung lockert die strenge
nullcovit-politik gegen die es zuletzt
auch heftige Proteste im Land gab nun
kommen Erleichterungen bei lockdowns
Quarantäne und testpflicht und heute gab
es aus Peking auch neue Daten zur
Wirtschaftslage die zeigen ihre massiven
Einbruch des chinesischen Außenhandels
Frank Bethmann wie sehr hängt die
corona-strategie in China mit der
Wirtschaftsentwicklung dort zusammen
zunächst mal hat auch die Experten
überrascht wie stark Chinas Exporte
zuletzt eingebrochen sind nämlich um
achteinhalb Prozent und man ahnt ja nur
wie sehr dazu vor allem diese strengen
lockdown-maßnahmen beigetragen haben die
ja nicht nur zur erheblichen
Produktionsausfällen geführt haben
sondern auch die Lieferketten haben
abreißen lassen und das alles hat auch
den Handel mit Deutschland schwer
belastet wie eben die neuesten Zahlen
für November zeigen dem nach vielen die
deutschen Ausfuhr nach China um über 17%
Chinas Exporte nach Deutschland ging um
über 14% zurück
klar ist dass die deutsche Wirtschaft
nun nach der Abkehr Chinas von der
harten corona-politik auf eine
Normalisierung kauft schließlich ist
China Deutschlands wichtigster
Handelspartner und bei allen Sorgen um
eine zu große Abhängigkeit von der
Volksrepublik kommt die deutsche
Industrie derzeit nur mit China aus der
Krise Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
auch nach dem frühen WM-Aus der
Nationalmannschaft bleibt Hansi Flick
Bundestrainer vor dieser fußballmeldung
des Abends hatte es ein Gespräch
zwischen Flick DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf und Vize Hans-Joachim Watzke
gegeben und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto
am Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr vier 14 16 30 37 39 Superzahl 8
und weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
an einem nachrichtentag an dem man
wieder einmal damit konfrontiert wird
wozu die Spezies Mensch so alles fähig
ist an Gewalt gegenüber anderen Menschen
aus Ideologie Machthunger oder
Verblendung schauen wir jetzt noch
darauf wie wir mit unserem Planeten
umgehen mit Natur und Tierwelt und
welche Hoffnungen auf der
weltnaturschutzkonferenz in Montreal
liegen Marco beginnt an einem Ort in
Deutschland den sich die Natur gerade
zurückerobern
Wildnis wo sie keiner vermutet zwischen
zerbrochenen Betonplatten da wo früher
Hubschrauber gestartet sind seit gut 20
Jahren wird der ehemalige Flugplatz in
Frankfurter Norden nach und nach grüner
die Natur kehrt zurück auch mit seltenen
Arten immerhin hier
deutschlandweit stehen dagegen
inzwischen mehr als 37% der Tier- und
Pflanzenarten auf der Roten Liste gelten
damit als gefährdet zu ihnen gehören
etwa die Schweinswale in der Ostsee
und auch feldvögel wie Kiebitz oder
Rebhuhn ihnen lässt der Mensch immer
weniger Platz zum Leben
mit unserem zügellosen Appetit auf
ungebremstes und ungleiches
Wirtschaftswachstum ist die Menschheit
zur Massenvernichtungswaffe geworden wir
behandeln die Natur wie eine Toilette
klare Worte zum Start der UNO-Konferenz
in Montreal erstmals seit zwölf Jahren
könnte sie nun wieder ein globales
Abkommen beschließen eines diesmal das
30% der Land und Meeresfläche der Erde
unter Schutz stellt so viel wie noch nie
einig ist man sich auf der Konferenz
aber noch lange nicht
es wird extrem knapp mit der Zeit und
die Länder müssen hier wirklich mit mehr
ambitionsniveau kommen die
minister:innen und Minister müssen hier
kommen mit dem wilden gemeinsam dieses
historische Abkommen zu verabschieden
und Sie müssen auch die nötige
Finanzierung bereitstellen damit das
gelingen kann
außerdem müssten sie sich auf
wirkungsvolle Regeln zur Umsetzung
einigen denn ambitionierte Zahlen
alleinreichen nicht deshalb müssen wir
auch Kriterien festlegen was es heißt 30
Prozent unter Schutzstellung damit wir
nicht bei sogenannten paper Parks landen
also Schutzgebieten die nur auf dem
Papier existieren
[Musik]
bei Biodiversität geht es um mehr als
einzelne Tier- und Pflanzenarten es geht
um vielfältige Ökosysteme um das
empfindliche Zusammenspiel des Lebens
dem Menschen bringt sie Nahrung Wasser
saubere Luft und Rohstoffe auch für
Medikamente die kleine städtische
Wildnis hier am alten Flugplatz im
Norden Frankfurts und sie ist immerhin
ein Anfang
das war von uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem auslandsjournal weiter
und um 0:55 Uhr meldet sich Gundula
Gause mit unserem heute schon mal Update
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend die Schauer Schleppe von
tief Zora begleitet uns heute Nacht und
auch morgen über Tag sie sehen aber wie
die Schauer hier ostwärts abziehen dann
wird es vorübergehend freundlich und von
den Alpen machen sich schon neue Schnee
und Schnee Regenfälle zu uns auf heute
Nacht beginnt es aber erstmal hier von
Nordwesten zu schneien in
Schleswig-Holstein in Hamburg bis zum
frühen Morgen dann auch in Mecklenburg
und im nördlichen Brandenburg morgen
ziehen diese schneefell über Tag dann
weiter ostwärts dann geht's noch weitere
Schnee Regenfälle rund um die
Mittelgebirge heute Nacht kann es aber
vielleicht sogar mal für einen
Wintergewitter an der Küste reichen da
können so 2 bis 5 cm schneeartig
vielleicht sogar 10 cm schneefallen
machen Sie sich also auf winterliche
Verkehrsverhältnisse gefasst im Süden
ist es dagegen trocken der bildet sich
zum Teil Nebel und am alten Rand singen
die Werte des minus sieben Grad sonst
liegen die Werte um den Gefrierpunkt und
nicht über den Gefrierpunkt hinaus
steigen Sie werte morgen hier im
Nordosten bei Schnee sind das nur so
null Grad 5 Grad werden es vielleicht am
Niederrhein oder auch an der Nordsee und
morgen geht es also weitere
Schneeschauer es könnten auch noch
letzte Wintergewitter hier in der Ostsee
sein freundlicher wird schon an der
Nordsee und auch in Süddeutschland und
in den nächsten Tagen geht es in jedem
Fall mal kalt weiter am Freitag kommt
dann schon der erste Schnee im Südosten
auf und der weitet sich dann bis zum
dritten Advent weiter Richtung Norden
aus guten Abend
Melanie Ammann wird heute bei uns zu
Gast sein wir freuen uns außerdem auf
den cdu-general auf Mario Czaja auf Olaf
Sundermeier und